my name is bonco nice to meet you bonco
yes I'm Sophia sorry that's some funny
name y this Dude Looks Like A Donkey
Kong
extra and his name is
bonco that is poetic where are you from
I'm from Bulgaria originally damn Bon's
ripped I love to work out do you work
out um yeah how many times a week
probably not as much as you what's your
favorite exercise in the
gym it's okay you know what remember we
did episode and there was that
Star Wars nerd who's just like so the
Tie Fighter went right into the Death
Star yeah remember that this is the same
same thing same thing cardio and then
cardio what's your favorite cardio
machine I guess just a treadmill
treadmill yeah did you inkline treadmill
uh when
they God bless him God bless him he was
really interested in this topic so he's
trying to connect with her on it but my
dude is not the way okay cuz then you
just look like a gym bro who thinks
about nothing but gym life that's why I
always tell people if you got a skill or
a talent like just don't make it your
whole personality you know it's kind of
like that guy who had to rise women up
and he's like I can sing and just starts
doing art and be in front of the girls
for the first time you said that you
would like sing to women in public yeah
that's definitely that's first place
because would not want to do that n
that's gimmicky and corny you got to be
some you sing to women in public
that's gimmicky as it's like saying
I can dance I don't be like if if every
time I be out here in public just be
like yo this salsa dance that's gimmicky
and that's for you know what it's like I
knew one guy he owned a bar okay yay
every time this approached a woman
he's like I have a bar it worked but
that is a crutch meaning you always
got to lean on the same thing to get a
him hi nice to meet you nice to meet you
your name Emily Emily yeah we're kind of
matching it's kind of a Vibe kind of I
kind of like the sing a lot what I
tell you that's a crutch what' I tell
you
girl I want to know your
name okay 1 hour
later it was red shirt
ready I respect the singing But if a guy
were to come up to me and start singing
probably
not that kind of corny and then the
only thing that you can respond is by
singing that's right so what's your name
oohoo like that makes no sense right
this look like they kind of dude if I
told him to flex for a woman he
immediately would you know what I mean
just like a monkey on demand he wasn't
asking he did yeah cuz he's like I know
what my strengths are but it's just like
if you lead too much with that you just
look like you're one-dimensional loser
that's what it looks like they tell me
to what are your favorite what's your
favorite now I'm so sorry why did you
reject me I think maybe you work out too
much for me I think you don't work out
enough Fair no no no you know what you
know what you know what you know what
it's equal you work out too much you
work out none enough it's the same thing
I like how she went you work out too
much and he went you don't work out
enough and she went mhm you can do that
yeah you can rebut me with what I said
to you me personally if somebody said to
me cuz I'm like I'm like cool not a
problem best of luck to you but I can
appreciate a good Petty moment this was
petty and I like it it's only Petty
because of the social construct of it
why is that what do you
mean cuz it's not well accepted to say
to someone that they don't work out
enough you can't say that to someone
that's fat phobic so we reacted to that
but essentially it's the same thing it's
just the opposite on the Spectrum you
work out too much you work out not
enough it's not the same thing that's
the equivalent of me saying you're too
rich and then you go you're too poor the
two do not mean the same thing or have
the same remote implications it does to
me yeah you know it doesn't oh hey hey
you're too good-looking well you're too
ugly you honestly think those two are
the same no but it's on the spectrum of
the things it it kind of is but it's not
it's not some like hey you're too
handsome you're too
ugly that is not the same thing one HTS
way more than the other yeah my name's
Ken how are you doing I'm good I'm
Sophia that's my daughter's name oh
daughter mhm she's four she about to be
five this
February is that a deal
[Music]
breaker this was about to
throw hands is that a deal breaker what
you do you want do you want well you
want to talk about my daughter yeah
you don't want my kids too I'll put a
baby in you
too get a baby by me baby be a broke
but just judging by your face
might be a broke but you can find
Allah look at my Bri that is a Muslim
brother what's his name Hamza what's
this guy's name it's got to be like
Hamza or something my name's Ken how are
you doing Hey listen listen
listen listen Kenneth Abdullah okay that
a deal
Breer um I don't know yeah I guess I
don't think so I guess not Sophia has
had Botox what do you think of
that yeah it didn't light up red but IID
have got out of here but did
you did you really get BOTOX I have
gotten a little Botox where at this
right here oh that might be crazy that's
a deal breaker I'm on natural Bab
why'd you do that I'll probably get more
Botox so oh that's crazy yeah we got to
go then he good you can bring a new girl
on if you want it's up to you okay I'm
going to go grab someone else bring him
in O I think that hurt
her I think that hurt her yeah yeah yeah
went went even though even though she
rejected him he rejected her yes cuz he
said yo we got we got to get right up
out of here n it's not read though I
would have he was a little bit too
transparent with his intention so he
lost but I ain't mad at the honesty but
I think she got hurt by that definitely
because you have to imagine if you're
insecure enough to want to get the botox
being made fun of or rejected because
you got the botox got a doubly hurt to
something it's not even cuz you think
you fixed it and everybody's like no
you're revolting for that decision it's
not even that is that for something is
little as like a bump or crazy here
that's something that you saw it's not
something that everybody was telling you
or it's like a big flaw some like
that like your eyes are not the same or
your eyes are crooked you know what I
mean it's just some little thing that
that's what your
insecurity or someone just made fun of
it once and it stayed with you for the
rest of your day and now like you said
you fixed that and I'm still going to be
like nah that's a no just because if you
fix what you thought was a flaw it means
you're you're never going to be what you
think is going to be the perfect thing
and on top of that you say that you yeah
it hurt it
definitely hello how's it going what's
your name name is Asia what do you do
for work business teacher at a high
school and then I coach on the side what
do you coach volleyball and basketball
oh I did volley okay I'm going to say
this and I say this with the most amount
of humility go ahead as someone with
up
eyebrows
you do have up eyebrows carry
on your whole is up man what
the is this that is not an eyebrow
that is an eye
train that kept going off to the
edge of her eyes what is that usually if
we talk about proportion your eyebrows
should finish about like the end of your
eye that is extended that's the
sequel right there that's a Trilogy
that's a Trilogy Matrix Reloaded that's
the that's that that no that's not
Matrix Reloaded that's the Lord of the
Rings I'm doing and the kids know which
is cool but you know we won some games
Good Times yeah good job that what they
do I'm sorry were you hitting it no I oh
you can hit it I'm sorry thank you I'm
out of here it's nice meeting you C how
you doing how you I'm doing good doing
how the other guys do um he was really
sweet and stuff he's really sweet just
not my type but it's okay it's not your
time see you again made the voice yeah
yeah so how you doing he got your time
yeah so he was really sweet yeah he was
really sweet that's good yeah all right
so I'm trying my best how cuz I'm a
short King does that does that so I need
to make sure my voice is perfect so so
yeah yeah girl how you do are you good
I'm good you good is your man on the
floor if you ain't let me know hey I'm
just saying Chris Breezy might have made
the track but I wrote it first nice
vibes from him I feel like I get nice
Vibes but I'm sure that you have like a
wild side that's the vibe I'm getting
yeah like I do got a wild side but you
just really got to get get to know me
and I don't let that out to everybody oh
interesting do you have a wild side I
would say I am fully myself all the time
and that's a lot how tall are you me I'm
5'4 who did yo she didn't have to put so
much she slamed dunk the button she uh
didn't press the button she beat up the
button she didn't have to gank
the button she didn't just can't it you
want show yeah no it was no she didn't
she didn't she didn't she that's what
she did she did she did she did she did
this get the out of here yeah
that's what that's what it was D was
54 Y St is
mosquito hi hello it's nice to meet you
nice to meet you Bo what's your name my
name's Asia Asia nice to meet you mea
meca nice to meet you mea I like your
outfit thank you I appreciate it I
appreciate it I have a question do you
find each other attractive I would say
yes oh thanks and you have a really nice
face and you have cool hair okay I
appreciate that let's practice something
hold each other's hands hold you hands
all right your hands feel kind of coarse
what what do you do for work I work with
my family's business uh it's a
Construction Services business oh that's
why yeah so I do like a lot of manual
labor and whatnot even when they're like
moisturized they're still like very like
rough there was lotion in the back what
I hey I have some native lotion you want
to go grab him some lotion like like
massage his hands check oh God Fu like
massages dick
ooh hey Button do not bad right now the
the button is a whole ass instigator
that's what the it
is what s is that Cy G it came out say
less we're like getting in this that's
cool nice okay that was good that was
good look my hands look better already
there you go I'm going to light up one
more time mhm and if you don't press me
you win the button and you get to go on
a second date and get to know each other
a little bit more sounds
good are you sure we're feeling it
that's up to you I'm positive you know
I'm comfortable where I stand this is
exciting all right so will you go on the
second date with me I will go on the
second date with you say less
congratulations you have won the
bunny that was kind of fun you know what
they might be going on the date but my
homie back when the teacher is
definitely the winner Xavier yeah he's a
winner winner winner chicken din that's
the winner of this whole show
shout outs to him and bonco I never want
to see you again I'm play bonco you keep
doing your thing and if you see me in
person be nice who's Bono Donkey Kong's
double not
double Bongo yeah I forgot about that
that's a dope name Bono is a dope name
it's just that when your name matches
your profession it's kind of
crazy you know I mean if you're an
arsonist and your name's flame like I'm
going to have a laugh
can I not have a laugh I'm going to
laugh that's all I'm saying anyways
anything else you want to say about this
no I'm all right let us know what you
guys think